[Música]
el 66% de los jóvenes en el perú ha sido
víctima de violencia física sexual o
psicológica el 45 por ciento de los
miembros de las pandillas son menores de
edad el 60 por ciento de los embarazos
se dan entre los 15 y los 19 años y hay
un 27% de niños y adolescentes que
trabajan
yo conocí a uno de ellos su nombre luís
carrera
él era croata de las calles de las
calles de lima
vivía en pachacútec me sorprendió que
las raíces de su pelo eran amarillas por
anne m
él hacía acrobacias en un semáforo para
poder brindar ingresos a su familia así
como louis existen miles de historias
que reflejan
estas cifras yo me pregunté cuál es el
problema común
un problema que sea común a todo esto y
me respondí la educación que entendemos
por educación educación viene de la
palabra educar que quiere decir sacar de
adentro educar no es sólo enseñar a
sumar restar enseñar a leer escribir
sino es dar las herramientas para poder
tener esa capacidad de resolver
problemas es dar herramientas para poder
adaptarse a los cambios
es enseñar herramientas de liderazgo
creatividad
actualmente vivimos
en un mundo muy cambiante la
inteligencia artificial por ejemplo ya
actualmente toma los trabajos de las
personas
en 10 ó 20 años se imaginan lo que va a
hacer eso estamos listos para enfrentar
eso en un comunicado de prensa el banco
mundial establecía advertía sobre una
crisis en el aprendizaje en la educación
a nivel mundial escolaridad no es lo
mismo que aprendizaje
lo mismo está sucediendo con la fuerza
laboral en un informe de
pricewaterhousecoopers del 2017 el 88%
de empresarios peruanos manifestó que
era sumamente difícil conseguir talento
con capacidad de liderazgo de
adaptabilidad a los cambios de
resolución de problemas entonces qué es
qué es lo que está pasando en este
informe de mckinsey company
sobre las pruebas pisa el 2015 algo muy
sorprendente sucedió fue la primera vez
que el universo económico no era el
determinante del aprendizaje sino las
habilidades blandas que son
efectivamente esas características
asociadas al liderazgo a la capacidad de
resolución de problemas entonces
hablemos de las habilidades blandas
cuál es la mejor manera de poder abordar
las habilidades blandas hoy estoy acá
para frente ustedes después de haber
estado hace cuatro años en un texto que
como bailarina habiendo emprendido un
programa con chicos que sean acordes en
un semáforo hoy día me paro acá frente
ustedes como una emprendedora social con
13 años de experiencia de campo
trabajando con miles de jóvenes y puedo
decirles que el arte es una herramienta
poderosísima de transformación y de
desarrollo social pero no el arte como
enseñarles plazos de baile no tengo ese
necesita de vale o te voy a enseñar una
canción es el proceso
es abordar el arte desde el interno es
mirarse uno mismo con lo bueno con lo
malo con esa verdad
y para eso lo que quiero es hacer una
dinámica con ustedes si me lo permiten
quisiera que por favor volteen a la
persona del costado y la miren en
silencio sin reírse a los ojos
profundamente hagan lo miren a la
persona al costado sin reírse en total
silencio y ahora sin decir quién empieza
empiecen simplemente a moverse empiecen
a moverse y el otro va a imitar ese
movimiento y no despeguen la mirada de
los ojos mírense todo el tiempo a los
ojos
gracias
pero algunos lo hicieron algunos no pero
en realidad es simplemente la orden de
moverse hace que tengan que mirarse y a
veces es difícil mirarse genera
sentimientos genera emociones genera una
serie de cosas que te mueven la palabra
motion viene de murcia la palabra
movimiento tiene la misma raíz
etimológica que emoción el arte
es la expresión
de esas emociones y son las emociones
las que determinan nuestro
comportamiento hoy día y ya sabemos que
nuestro cerebro es emocional sabemos que
nosotros percibimos el mundo a través de
los sentidos pero una vez que entran lo
vamos a percibir acordé a esos recuerdos
porque pasa por un órgano maravilloso
que tenemos en el lóbulo temporal que se
llama amígdala si la amígdala es el
núcleo del control de las emociones y
sentimientos yo lo entiendo como el
director de orquesta que dirige nuestra
conducta a partir de nuestras emociones
son importantes las emociones
definitivamente
además la vida está asociada al lóbulo
frontal el logro frontal se desarrolla
en la adolescencia y es el lóbulo
humanoide es el lóbulo que nos hace
humanos es el lóbulo del control de la
inhibición yo no sabía nada de esto hace
13 años hace 13 años mi sueño era ser
una bailarina profesional era lo que más
quería me fui a europa y siempre pensaba
que era haber logrado ser bailarina
principal en irlanda luego me convoca el
circo del sol y digo ya mi sueño está
cumplido pero no conozco a luis carrera
y otros 40 jóvenes que no tenían
oportunidades pero que no estaban siendo
víctimas sino estaban viendo la manera
de sobrevivir y eso me movió tanto que
es que realmente cambió mi propósito
cambió mi propósito de vida para siempre
cambio
y además renuncie a eso por lo que había
luchado desde que tenía tres años
nunca imaginé que esa renuncia nunca
imaginé que esa renuncia
generaría un vínculo tan fuerte y tan
potente de confianza en un país de
absoluta desconfianza nunca imaginé que
estaba rompiendo un paradigma en ese
momento empecé a trabajar con estos 40
chicos empecé a trabajar con ellos
creando un espacio comunitario un
espacio donde poníamos todas nuestras
reglas con disciplina con una estructura
pero mirándonos a los ojos sin juicio
como acaban de hacer ustedes o algunos
de ustedes
empezamos a desarrollar pasos
coreografías entre todos a retarnos en
un espacio de contención y esto elevado
a la autoestima en todos ellos
si van generando todos estos elementos
no nos damos cuenta que los 20 que
quedaron y otras personas que se sumaron
lo que estábamos haciendo era gestar una
organización una filosofía un movimiento
estabamos fundando de uno en de uno lo
que hacemos es brindar oportunidades a
jóvenes y adolescentes
usando el arte específicamente la danza
y el desarrollo humano
para una transformación lo hacemos
también a través de un programa de
liderazgo gratuito
pueden ver acá los chicos graduándose el
diplomado en la upc lo hacemos a través
de nuestras escuelas lo hacemos a través
de nuestros espacios comunitarios lo
hacemos a través de nuestros
espectáculos que siempre buscan un
impacto social como imaginar que un
chico como jesús que ha sido líder de
una de las patillas más bravas en un
barrio en un distrito de lima
se iba a convertir en un expositor de
ted o iba a ser un líder para miles de
jóvenes en los barrios más difíciles y
más peligrosos de lima como vi a
imaginar que una chica como genoveva que
vivía en pachacútec y que ha sido
víctima de violencia doméstica terrible
a sus 21 años estaba coordinando un
programa para naciones unidas para la
seguridad humana como mi imaginar un
chico como louis carrera que lo conocía
y de 13 años hoy día se ha graduado de
una prestigiosa universidad en eeuu está
entre los 8 mejores 20 áncer del mundo y
acaba de iniciar su startup que es lo
que pasó con ellos ellos el grado donde
este programa de esta metodología pues
es una metodología que combina cuatro
componentes las artes expresivas el
desarrollo del ser lo comunitario y la
danza y el desarrollo humano aborda
valores pero valores validados por ellos
no el valor que te dicen y qué haces el
valor realizado por ellos y eso les da
un sentido de pertenencia un sentido
identitario al igual que una pandilla
ese sentido de pertenencia les permite a
ellos proyectarse y tener un proyecto
futuro
y teniendo todo eso recién podemos
introducir habilidades técnicas y
contenidos así funciona
el movimiento el teatro foro el rap la
improvisación lo que hace es generar un
pensamiento fuera de lo racional cuando
tú te pones en ese círculo al centro te
ponen la música la sueltan y vas a
improvisar no racionaliza es el
movimiento solamente lo haces te
entregas al movimiento te entregas a la
sensación y eso es pura emoción y la
emoción no puede estar equivocada
imagínense más aún si tienes a un grupo
que lo contiene y lo valida sucede la
magia sucede la magia y realmente ese
joven es adolescente es el niño
hasta ese adulto empieza a valorarse y
empezó a pasar de ser invisible a ser
visible a ser resiliente hemos impactado
a más de 200.000 jóvenes adolescentes
llegamos a siete mil jóvenes y hay una
cifra que me encanta que es 9 de 10
graduados trabajan y los que están
trabajando están en una capacitación más
del 50% trabaja por vocación trabaja en
lo que ama
en sólo seis meses tenemos un aumento de
30% de resiliencia tu eficacia
autoestima bienestar en fin y poseer
algo que empezó como intuición y por
amor
funciona
y se ha convertido porque juntos hemos
estado
en realidad un movimiento y una
metodología que hoy hemos sistematizado
un programa innovador y esa metodología
que hemos sistematizado nos ha permitido
lograr cosas que se gestaban como
imposibles que se decían imposibles nos
dijeron no imposible cómo vamos a hacer
un festival urbano pues lo hicimos
hicimos un festival internacional
tenemos ya siete ediciones es un
festival sin apoyo del estado que ya ha
sido nominado por y es bien como el
mejor festival de latinoamérica convoca
a más de 250.000 jóvenes
que van a divertirse una plataforma
cultural nos dijeron que produjera
imposible nos fuimos a nueva york hemos
presentado en londres en nueva york'
fuimos elegidos y pudimos presentar en
el min confieren al lado de chicago de
hamilton de las principales compañías
del mundo
el 85% de nuestros egresados manifiesta
que vive una vida plena a mí eso me hace
el día nace el año nace la vida el saber
que el 85% nos regresamos tiene una vida
plena
con un modelo como el que tenemos
sistematizado y replicable estos líderes
están gestando ya están emulando esta
metodología en sus propias comunidades
silvana
cristian
yo él
son sólo algunos ejemplos de los chicos
que se están formando que se están
formando y están replicando tenemos
una herramienta muy poderosa ya es
momento que la educación mire al arte
como una opción como una opción válida
da verdadera y no solo para los jóvenes
con los que empezó el programa sino para
los niños para los adultos para todos
porque realmente funciona tenemos algo
que puede conectarnos y puede cambiar el
perú y puede cambiar el mundo usémoslo y
usemos lo ya gracias
[Aplausos]